sua fraca e agora vai abrir eu acho que
é um trash todo o lado pessoal de quem
fala andar que sejam muito bem vindos a
amazona grega e mostra que o mais um
vídeo de destruição do cop
ele tá bem duras qual é muito blindada
não esse é de alta segurança isto é o
blindado blindado já destruiu só eu
prometo que eu trazia outro vídeo de se
eu conseguisse destruir o cofre anterior
e isso aconteceu eu já destruiu um cofre
normal já destruiu um cofre do blindado
e este é o cofre de alta segurança é
muito resistente sério aqui na caixa a
favor da caixa de chicletes extinto o
fogo e se matou
mas não interessa o que sua luz vamos
destruir aqui o nosso cofre pessoal eu
vou precisar de muita força pra curtir
isso olha só é muito duro o lei os
fagundes nenhuma por e defina é tudo
grosso ainda não sei se vocês lembram
mais nos cofres entre outros deve sempre
um aparelho mais fina e toda a parede
deste cofre e grossa é muito graça
porque porque é um cofre da alta
segurança passado e faz nada
a obra fosse assim eu não queria dar
segurança e sim o fogo não está manchada
depois só começar é mais fofo né eu já
tenho as minhas ferramentas virtuais ao
time uma chata picareta o martelo em
estúdio eu vou tentar abrir o cofre com
em folhas o que começou após ela e à sua
quinta porque tem muito feliz dentro eu
vou tentar bater com força
olha eu acho que vai furar rapidez
invadindo a gente tem que começar aqui
de treino cofre pessoal quanto com a
vossa ajuda vamos todos deixar com um
mega light que neste vídeo é porque isso
ajuda muito que o canal espaços porém
nós aqui no canal inscreva se em baixo
que atribuiu se nem para receberem todos
os vídeos que vão lançar agora se é de
alta segurança imagino próximo cofre
tempo vai-se que cofre do banco não sei
chegando lá dentro eu não consegui
encontrar um corpo mais potente do que a
série c é muito duro até aqui traje
blindado
olha isso já me importa só ver o grosso
da emel é muito grossa olha aí foi dilma
vem o negro do chão e das paredes ok eu
acho que é assim mesmo impossível
destruir este copo eu aqui se mata por
aceitava destruir mas vejam grossura da
parede e do teto olha aqui olha só o
teto koff é muito grosso machado nunca
vai passar isso nunca
henrique xavier chaves chave agora é o
primeiro passo como sempre é fechar o
cofre fechado à chave aqui e vamos
tentar fechar o trinco não sei se vai
funcionar ainda está preso é o agora foi
agora é só fechar o nosso corpo e portar
só agora 'taxa pessoal ninguém vai
conseguir e bischoff fosse reparado que
tem um painel eletrônico mas não precisa
de pilha eu não vou perder tempo a
configurar aqui o panela então é só
destruído conforme já sabem não brinquem
com essas coisas em casa só que isso é
muito perigoso eu posso fazer porque
porque peguei uma das minhas ferramentas
favoritas
este martelo aqui ó marcelo tokman acho
que a nossa e isso não é a eu vou
apresentar oo o abril e não fez nada
pessoal aportar intacta e uma louca que
eu descobri e que traz um ponto fraco e
voltar o cofre vocês vão ver comigo que
é isso que falei o que é isso eu acho
que eu conseguir isso que marcou 12
eu acho que sim eu tive com o pé de
cabra tenho pique e tênis o que queria
dizer que eu não sei se esta tarde a não
é machista racista ok eu preciso para o
cofre pro chão quebrando parte da mesa e
agora vamos tentar abrir futebol já tô
cansado só de segurar o cofre no último
vídeo cansei muito mesmo só para abrir o
cofre se que ainda mais potente vamos
fazer eu já saí de lá pessoal martelo
contra cofre em 321 vai bem por dentro
eu tenho muito medo dessas coisas alta
podem estar a resultar até ter um pó
branco que foi isso que eu fiz um bom
com isso um burro ea lusofonia mil haja
se o que suei para leandro já só pra
fazer isso eu toparei ferry para casa
vamos lá eles um banho ou entrou muito
agora só entrou muito agora falei isso
entrou muito agora meu deus eu acho que
só assim vou conseguir abrir mais fácil
vai fácil a lei tem muito pó é fácil em
casa faça com segurança que enganados ou
eu fui na água imagine só que eu
esconder uma jóia e não brasil roubar
jóias logo solta como acha que vai abrir
e eu vou tentar porque o painel primeiro
aí vamos ver o quão resistente à porta
do cofre o que esse pessoal tem é que
xavi tocou
acho que assim me mandar embora mas é
isso que vou fazer agora eu vou mandar
ele para que usar dentro do já só vai à
rua azul espera que o gatuno a chave é
dali que me deu um aperto de mãos é isso
vou tentar agora brilha que o cofre com
uma chave e outro com medo porque essa
lâmina da silva ac lâmina tá serviço vai
ser perigoso e por isso não podem fazer
isso em casa só eu sou eu porque é uma
coisa que não existe
a atriz um bairro ou ruins autos que a
costura e por que esse suporte e
destruiu o painel tudo está a funcionar
aqui mesmo então aí já não vou fazer mas
só 7 mesmo dia cumprida deles só ficar
no sporting movido a lei bem porque tem
um líquido estranho ler o que vou tentar
porque uma história triste não vai
faltar tudo pois não só pessoal só tem
uma coisa lá dentro em estranha capturar
um certo o que causa insegurança mas
ainda falta a queima se eleito vou
tentar porque disse que o pânico
estranho
leonêncio nossa ae muito contrariada em
31 bairros ainda vai mais falei só certo
muito cansado mas está valendo a pena aí
também portista muito partida que está
na altura de usar a picareta agora aqui
sim mesmo aqui dentro eu acho que a
briga portanto ela eu acho que sou eu já
vou com meus fãs por vezes eu também tô
curioso é que o tamanho da estátua terá
estatuto quer usar esse mesmo embora o
a321 preta contra cofre hall ou ficou
ficou na porta o play habitam esse
momento isso foi um mesmo aparelho e
voltar mais
só vou tentar furar o chão do cofre esta
parte aqui já e burla 32 eo vai já fruto
primeira pequena e tem muito tempo a
alceu também no centro
foram oito ou até preencher o deus
eu vou tentar se dar bem em uma e outra
vez mais tempo teria cola vai 31
a roupa tem um trunfo lento mas 5º joão
buracão por aí eu coloquei em um buraco
enorme
eu acho que não é a porta tem que abrir
até ficar completamente aberto então
ainda não consegui só vou tentar agora o
máximo de força possível agora vai
mandar no trecho 2 foi o mesmo sítio
o leitor se tem mesmo que o buraco não
acredita tanto no ranking de tampa na
altura dos olhos de nossos pecados
agora vai não vou usar essa bola
[Risadas]
explodiu em uma igreja ou buraco no
tanque
olha aí como assim muita pedra muito
frágil e itajaí
eu acho que sim acho que saí ele acha
ele acha o chão daqui já tá se esqueçam
da claque toque final é duro é bem dura
guinada só estava lá e perguntar vou
abrir o cofre
o metrô só vou saber que tá preta que
funciona melhor que então o martelo
agora que vai manter é o hotel se sérgio
mateus traga muito eles acham da entrar
tudo em tudo tudo como assim sem mais
pedro do ferro eo local em que estou
cansado olha aí no meio do filme
agora isso acho que dá pra explicar
representar meus abril mas já tá vendo
como é que eu acho mais uma ou duas
pancadas de chuvas só assim é que agora
vai abrir eu acho que tem 32
o costa clássica de uso de nenhum eu to
cansado dói muito
os bairros vou concentrar software vista
vai ter que o chakra lindo disse eu
perguntei eu prometi que ia abrir o
cofre mas eu ainda vou destruir mais
numa lacuna em 321 vai 321 vai continuar
vivendo essa já saiu o eca já sabe que
eu sou muito inteligente eu sou muito
gênio para encerrar a dobradiça
encaixada por aqui por cima logo se eu
marcar por baixo da porta e saí com um
não é
falei olha aí uma clara se ela saiu e eu
acho que é importante já está destruindo
o pouco do tua boca assine aqui só mais
um ou dois meses a casa tá né
nenê conseguiu arrancar a porta para
isso está no nosso cofre de sua estátua
foi o tempo em que um pouquinho mas está
tudo bem tudo bem mas mesmo assim acho
que o cofre anterior e não me canso mais
mas está aqui também foi muito
complicado e só estou muito cansado mas
espero que vocês tenham gostado que
desfila e deixei muito mais quiserem
captar um cofre novo explorer office
aqui no canal inscreva-se com toda força
porque vai ser muito vídeo novo ea tvi
assim também porque isso é muito
importante as pessoas querem um estado
fiquem bem até a próxima temporada vou
bater mais ainda
[Música]